oh
hb-a vous au palau magasins auront reçu
et de la récupération c'est pour secours
populaire voilà comment dans les
plaintes
a beaucoup petites violences hélas ici
si on se base elle a les joues si si
allez allez pas de ça avec moi hein
voilà
il peut pour le
petit père n'a à ma main attendez que je
te gâche mon d'autres n'ont su prendre
celle d'or
non tu saoules quoi vous n'avez pas
mentir landais pour une petite bosse
pourquoi juste un peu quoi
as tu peux être là bas ça vous est alors
bien sûr chaloupe à mais si on prend
pour les abonnés à
cette petite boule réalité là bas vous
remettez ça là pourquoi je m'y attendais
vraiment mon sac tu t'y mayol où quoi tu
crois ou là ah ben je réponds moi c'est
pas écrit de succès alors j'ai vu un
homme maintenant ça se voit pas l'abruti
ou quoi pourquoi calcul enlever celle là
la vertu l'armée au dollar mais où tu
l'a prise je sais plus à qui l'armée ou
de la prise dans le sac alors qu'il a
prise dans le sact l'armée là dedans
plus la prise a donc dans le sac c'est
toi qui l'a pris dans le sacré
que ce soit un
travail après un casse toi je te dis
merde pas gentil un tir toile à aller
françois sympa tire toi de l'attentât
regarde-moi sarrians moi rire massa ce
que tu as fait casse-toi [ __ ] je te
colle une arête une casse toi tu as de
la colle ouais ça s'écoute
comme moi ça tu matouk radoter mon sac
cabas une toute petite balle
ciscodelaluna
arrête de dire [ __ ] tu dis des gros
mots c'est pas bien pour noël toi et si
t'as pas de cadeau en or il faudra pas
venir pleurer un bon méchant
[Musique]